ungefähr
five minutes for
questions and answers. And we have a really exciting
set of talks looking at longer-term outcomes from
traditional immunotherapeutics as well as novel
immunotherapeutics with some translational and
correlative work that's associating that.
And so what I'd like to do is to go very
quickly into our first presentation, Dr.
Memi, who's at the Angeles Clinic and Research Institute just
down the street from us at UCLA,
and he will be presenting on GV20.
Thank you to AACR and Dr. Garraway and Dr.
Khoshali for allowing us to present this data on
GV20-0251. We'll be looking at the
pharmacodynamics and predictive biomarkers.
This is an anti-IGSF8 antibody as
monotherapy conducted in phase one and two, a study.
These are my disclosures.
So GV20-0251 is an anti-IGSF8
human antibody towards a novel checkpoint,
IGSF8, that was discovered by GV20 Pharmaceuticals or
Therapeutics, sorry, through a proprietary AI platform.
The preclinical data has shown that IGSF8 inhibition by
this particular monoclonal antibody or loss of IGSF8
by knockout suppresses tumor growth through
enhancing NK cell cytotoxicity and dendritic
cell-mediated antigen presentation.
You see the cartoon for the mechanism and also the two
preclinical data sets showing tumor regression
with the treatment
either as a single agent or with anti-PD-1 leading to
regression in tumor and also the knockout model
tumor regression.
So based on that preclinical data, we conducted a phase one monotherapy dose
escalation study. Fifty-two patients were assessed for
eligibility, and 42 patients were enrolled into part
A, and this was a three plus three non-randomized
design allocated to
GV20-0251 monotherapy at two different dosing schedule,
one at day one, day eight every three weeks, and the second one was
day one of every three weeks. Those are the dosing listed below.
Here's the patient demographics.
I'd like to bring your attention to the number of different tumor types treated
on this particular early phase study, with the majority of the
patient being cutaneous melanoma.
Additionally, most of these patients had been treatment experienced
either as standard of care therapy being immunotherapy in single agent or
in combination with anti-CTLA4 or LAG-3.
The waterfall plot here shows you the best percent change based on
RECIST 1.1. The 42 patients that were treated, out
of them, 37 were evaluable for a response assessment.
Of these 37 patients, 16 patients had cutaneous
melanoma, and of those 16, three showed confirmed
response.
When we dove deeper into these melanoma patients,
looking at nine of them had primary resistant disease, meaning
prior PD-1 or combination therapy did not show any response.
Out of those nine patients, three had partial response and
additional three with additional tumor shrinkage.
Two of these PR or partial responding patients had liver
metastases, which we know to be immune therapy
resistant site. This constituted an
objective response rate of 33.3% and disease control rate of
77.8%. One of these patients
was on monotherapy for up to about two years.
Here is a representation of three patients' images showing
response. The first patient had a non-weight-bearing
cutaneous melanoma
of the foot
with a large lesion in the foot itself that
shows a regression of disease. Other two patients had liver predominant
disease showing, again, response.
In addition to very encouraging clinical activity, here I
show you the favorable safety profile when we're looking at treatment-related
adverse events of any grade, fatigue, rash, nausea, and
pruritus.
When we're looking at all these dosing
levels, we did not see
any dose-limiting toxicity or dose-dependent trends
in these treatment-related adverse events.
We had only one patient with grade three pneumonitis, possibly related
to GV20-021,
but we think that this was in context of a progression, perhaps,
maybe not pneumonitis, but again, still
related to the treatment. No other grade three or greater
treatment-related adverse events were noted at any of these dose levels.
With respect to pharmacodynamics, looking at these two different
dosing mechanisms, either at every day one, day eight of a
three-week schedule or day one of Q3 weekly schedule, we've
estimated half-life of about 26 days without any
detection of significant ADAs, anti-drug antibodies, or serum
cytokine
signals.With
respect to pharmacodynamics, we see full target occupancy of
circulating T cells at a dose greater than three milligrams per kilogram
prior to cycle two, day one. Additionally, diminished
target expression upon JV21-0251 treatment
on circulating T cells.
With respect to migration of NK cells and
CD8 positive T cells, we do see
increased
cell numbers in tumor microenvironment with the pretreatment and
on-treatment biopsy analysis. You can see that there's a percent increase
of CD56 positive cells per tumor cells, as
well as CD8 positive T cells. The depiction on the
right with immunohistochemistry shows that there's an increased
infiltration of anti-CD8 positive T cells
post-treatment or while patients are on treatment.
Here's the RNA seq data showing increase in antigen-presenting
cells,
dendritic cells, as well as NK cell
activity
while patients are on treatment compared to their baseline, showing an
increase in inflammatory microenvironment in
tumor.
When we looked back at some of these responding patients, what we
seen is that
patients who have high expression of IGSF8 are the ones that
tended to show that response. And this response
is
independent of PD-L1, as you can see that when you're looking at
PD-L1 and IGSF8 expression
via immunohistochemistry, there seems to be an opposite
relationship. PD-L1 is negative, whereas
IGSF8 is positive.
Additionally, beyond melanoma, we also know that IGSF8
expression is
present in a number of different other malignancies.
For example, hepatocellular carcinoma, non-small cell lung cancer, small cell
lung cancer, triple-negative breast cancer, and prostate that tend to have a
fairly high
IGSF8 expression.
In conclusion, JV20-0251 demonstrated promising
clinical activity in phase one monotherapy dose escalation, particularly in
melanoma patients that are resistant to standard of care
immunotherapies.
Responding patients tend to have a higher IGSF8
expression, perhaps a biomarker.
JV20-0251 exhibited a favorable safety and PK
profile with a 26-day half-life,
allows us to dose it every three weeks conveniently.
JV20-0251 induced a robust target
modulation and immune stimulatory effects in treated
tumor consistent with our preclinical findings.
For that reason, we think that irrefractory neoplasm with high IGSF8 may
be potentially benefiting from JV20-0251 treatment.
Based on this early phase data, a phase two
cohort as monotherapy or in combination with anti-PD-1 are
currently enrolling. Happy to take any questions.
Thank you very much. Reminding people that you can
submit questions, but we do have a first question at the microphone there.
It's nice. Do you know what is a receptor for IGSF8 expressed
on T cells and NK cells apparently?
We believe it's more on the tumors rather than the receptor.
When we look at the CPS and TPS scores, they are very similar,
so most of the expression appears to be on
the tumor's cells rather than on the immune cells, if that
was your question.
Yeah, but the IGSF8 has to act on NK cells and T cells according
to your data, right? So there has to be some kind of inhibitory molecule that
recognize the IGSF8.
At the moment, what we know is that the expression is on the
tumor, and the subsequent studies will help us find that further.
Thank you. We'll go to the middle microphone.
It's just a follow. You might have mentioned it.
So I think it's Kire 3-DL2 is
one of the ligands.
So I think the question
the previous questioner meant was,
did you look at ligand
expression for the IGSF8?
For the IGSF8-
Or actually,
receptor expression.
I don't have the data to answer that question, but we'll be looking into that.
Go to the microphone there.
Nice presentation. I assume the responders or the response was
durable response.
Yes. So we have confirmed PR in three patients.
Perfect. And which dose you are taking to the phase two?
I'm sorry, I didn't hear.
Which dose?
The dose. Twenty?
Dose. So the durable response has been
seen at 10 milligram per kilogram and 20 milligram per
kilogram every three weekly dose.
So the phase two dose will be 20?
Right. I believe a 10 or 20 milligrams at monotherapy or in combination.
We'll go back over to the microphone there.
Yeah. My question is because your safety profile is quite good, so what's
the reason behind it? Because target NK and the APC,
but not immune cells, not T cells?
I believe by modulating the IGSF8, we're
increasing the NK cell, dendritic cell,
and the CD8 T positive T cell infiltration and allowing
tumor control.Okay. Thank you.
The middle microphone.
Hi. Fantastic talk. My name is Jelani Zarif. I'm from Johns Hopkins.
I had a question about your prostate cancer histology.
Were those in localized disease, Gleason score?
Do you have any of that? Or those castrate-resistant tumors, neuroendocrine tumors?
No, not at the moment. We just wanted to show that
there are other tumor subtypes that do have IGSF8 expression and
perhaps can benefit once explored into.
But you don't know what Gleason score those tumors might have been
from or grade or... Because in prostate
cancer, that can
change, right? Some tumors have low AR, no AR,
mutated AR, neuroendocrine. So I was just wondering if you had those
details.
I can look that up for you and then get you the answer.
But at the moment, I do not have that.
Thank you.
Go back to that.
You showed that if
IGSF8 is present, then PD-L1 is very low.
There's an inverse relationship.
What's the rationale of combining it with an anti-PD-1
antibody for your phase 2 that you were talking about?
That's a very good question.
The limited data that we have
post IGSF8 blockade with GV20,
we seem to show increased expression of
PD-L1. That was part of the rationale of combining it with
anti-PD-1 therapy.
Okay, the middle.
Can you comment, what was the Fc fragment of an antibody?
What was the Fc isotype? Was it IgG1, IgG4?
I
believe it's IgG4.
Thanks.
Okay.
Well, great. I think we're both on time and unless I'm
missing somebody, I think that the people who are at microphones to ask questions
have asked them. So thank you very much.
And next, I'd like to invite up Dr. Timothy Yap from the MD Anderson Cancer
Center, presenting on the first-in-human Phase 1 study of
PLN101-095, a first-in-class dual integrin
inhibitor as monotherapy and in combination with pembrolizumab in patients with
advanced solid tumors refractory to immune checkpoint inhibitors.
Thank you very much. Good morning, everyone, and thank you for
being here. On behalf of my co-investigators, I want
to thank the AACR Organizing
Committee for giving us this opportunity to share with you today
data from our first-in-human Phase 1 study of
PLN101-095, a first-in-class
dual alpha V beta 8, alpha V
beta 1 integrin inhibitor as monotherapy
and in combination with pembrolizumab in
patients with advanced solid tumors refractory to immune checkpoint
inhibitors.
These are my disclosures.
PLN101-095 is a novel oral
integrin alpha V beta 8 and alpha V beta
1 inhibitor.
In response to sustained immune activity, solid tumors
utilize integrin alpha V beta 8 and alpha V
beta 1 activation of TGF beta to
suppress and escape immune control.
And with that in mind, PLN101-095 was designed
to potently block integrin alpha V beta 8 and alpha V
beta 1-driven activation of TGF beta
locally in a tumor microenvironment.
And this is different from past strategies of systemically
targeting the active TGF beta cytokine, the
TGF beta receptor kinase, or specific
isoforms of TGF beta.
PLN101-095 also selectively
enhances T cell interferon gamma effector
function and reduces fibroblast
activation and fibrotic tumor stroma.
It's also been shown to combine well with orthogonal IO approaches
such as PD-1, PD-L1 inhibitors.
And therefore, our hypothesis was that the inhibition
of integrin alpha V beta 8 and alpha V
beta 1 blocks the activation of TGF beta to reduce
immunosuppression, leading to a new or reinvigorated
cancer immune response.
PLN101-095 promotes immune checkpoint inhibitor
responsiveness by inhibiting TGF beta
and increasing interferon expression, as evidenced by
the tumor gene expression changes after treatment, as shown here
in EMT6 tumor models dosed with
PLN101-095.
And as shown in the figure on the right, by inhibiting TGF beta,
PLN101-095 shifts solid tumors to
a high
interferon gamma signature
and an immune checkpoint inhibitor responsive state.
And with that in mind, that provided the preclinical evidence to proceed
to a Phase 1 open label dose escalation study
in patients with advanced solid tumors with prior immune
checkpoint inhibitor resistance.
All patients received PLN101-095 on
day one as monotherapy. Pembrolizumab was added on
day 15 in combination.
We then assessed their tumor response at week 10
and subsequently every eight
weeks.For dose escalation, we initially
used an acceleration titration design followed by a full
Bohan dose escalation Phase 1 trial design.
We started at a dose of 250 milligrams BID
and escalated to the top dose of 2,000 milligrams
BID.
We have now completed dose escalation with all dose levels
cleared.
Study population comprised patients who had prior exposures to
PD-1 therapies with documented disease progression.
All patients had primary or secondary resistance as defined by
CIrcie.
Primary and secondary endpoints included treatment emergent adverse
events, serious treatment emergent adverse events, and
also DLTs, as well as pharmacokinetics.
Exploratory endpoints included anti-tumor activity and
changes in blood-based biomarkers.
These are the patient baseline characteristics.
We treated a total of 16 patients, median age of
60 years. There were equal numbers of males and
females. The most common tumor types included non-small cell lung
cancer, cholangiocarcinoma, squamous cell
cancer of the head and neck, and also RCC.
This was a heavily pre-treated patient population with a median of
three prior lines of therapy
and up to four.
Seventy-five percent of patients had secondary resistance to
prior immune checkpoint inhibitors.
In general, PLN101095 was well-tolerated and safe.
You can see that the toxicities were mainly Grade 1 to Grade 2.
Grade 3 toxicities were rare. The most common
treatment-related adverse events included rash, fatigue,
hypomagnesemia, and pruritus. The most common
treatment-related adverse event was rash.
All rashes were Grade 1 to Grade 2.
One treatment-related rash was reported during the monotherapy
period, but otherwise, these were primarily observed within two
days of starting combination treatment.
Here are the PK data. PLN101095
as monotherapy demonstrates dose-ordered exposures at
day 14.
All patients receiving at least 1,000 milligrams BID of
PLN101095 maintained IC75
coverage over 24 hours, supporting consistent
target engagement.
And this PK profile supports continuous pharmacologic
inhibition with BID dosing at steady state.
Here are the efficacy data. You can see in this waterfall plot the responses were
observed, including patients with secondary immune
checkpoint inhibitor resistance.
There were four iRecist responders, including a complete response in
an advanced cholangiocarcinoma patient.
Two confirmed partial responses, one in non-small cell lung cancer and
one in melanoma, and one unconfirmed partial response in a head and
neck squamous cell carcinoma patient.
In the overall study population, the overall response rate
was 19%, with a disease control rate of
56%.
In the population with immune checkpoint inhibitor secondary resistance, the
overall response rate was 30% and the disease
control rate of 60%.
In this spider plot, you'll see clinically significant
durable responses observed in three out of the four iRecist
responses were treated at doses of 1,000 milligrams
BID and above. The median time on treatment
was 19 months for the three confirmed objective
responses, who had an average maximum
tumor reduction of -89%.
I'm going to end by discussing two of our patients. This is a patient of Dr.
Manish Sharma. This is a 63-year-old male with
cholangiocarcinoma, diagnosed back in 2019.
He's got a background history of Lynch syndrome and prior history of other tumors.
You can see this patient was heavily pre-treated with different lines of
chemotherapy and also with pembrolizumab before
eventually developing disease progression that was confirmed.
And you can see gradual tumor shrinkage over time.
As you can see here, eventually leading to an iRecist complete response.
And this patient is still on trial today at greater than
106 weeks on study and tolerating
treatment extremely well.
The second patient is from
Dr. Alex Spira. This is a 57-year-old female with TMB high,
non-small cell lung cancer diagnosed back in 2020.
One prior line of therapy including pembrolizumab for 35 months,
eventually developing disease progression that was confirmed.
The patient also had radiation in the past for treatment.
Again, you'll see tumor shrinkage over time, eventually achieving
an iRecist partial response, and this patient was on trial
for 66 weeks.
As an exploratory endpoint, clinical response to
PLN101095 was associated with
elevated plasma interferon gamma,
as shown in the graph on the left-hand side,
and also elevated levels of PD-L1, as shown in the graph on the
right, after 14 days of monotherapy.
And so we believe that increases in interferon gamma
during monotherapy may actually act as a potential
biomarker of TGF-beta inhibition, and this will indeed
be studied now in our dose expansion
cohorts.So to
conclude, PLN101-095 was
generally well-tolerated
in the dose escalation portion of this Phase 1 study, with
no new safety concerns emerging when the integrin inhibitor was
combined with pembrolizumab.
Early signals of anti-tumor activity was observed in patients
with immune checkpoint inhibitor secondary resistance.
The overall response rate was 30%, disease control rate
of 60%.
Circulating interferon gamma may be a potential
biomarker for early prediction of treatment response.
And finally, those expansion cohorts have now been initiated
in advanced non-small cell lung cancer, clear cell renal cell cancer, and
TMB high cancers.
These data for PLN101-095 in combination
with pembrolizumab suggest a potential to meet a high unmet
clinical need amongst these patients with secondary resistance to immune
checkpoint inhibitors with no new safety concerns.
To end, I would like to thank all of our patients and their caregivers,
our sponsor, Pliant Therapeutics, and also editorial
assistants from Nucleus Global. Thank you very much. Thank you.
So please put questions in the chat and we'll prioritize room questions.
So we can start with the first microphone on the left here.
Thank you very much for the presentation, Gabriel Fringana, Cambridge, United
Kingdom. I have a questions in terms of the tumor activity.
Do you expect it to be different in tumors who have-
I'm sorry, we can't hear you.
Can you hear me now? Oh,
sorry.
Questions regarding the tumor activity.
Do you expect to see a difference in tumor which have a high
interferon gamma response due to cell autonomous effects
from C-gastins, for example, compared to those who don't
have high interferon gamma
response?
I think potentially. I think that needs to be looked into.
But the principle here is that we can actually induce
the interferon gamma and also potentially elevate the PD-L1
levels and then reinvigorate, I guess,
these tumors to be sensitive to
immune checkpoint inhibitors again in combination with this drug, of course.
Thank you. Thanks for that question.
We can move to the middle microphone here.
Yeah. Thank you very much. Nice go through.
So I have a question about the cohort of CRC you included in your
clinical trial. Can you elaborate whether these are
MSS or MSI?
Great question. I don't know off the top of my head, but if you come look for me
later, we can dig into those questions for you, into those individual patients.
Very hard to know offhand.
Thank you.
And moving to the far right microphone.
So I noticed you use iResist instead of resist, and I wanted to know if there was
a difference between the two, if you look at the resist responses,
and how did iResist help in terms of determining responses in this
population?
Yeah. Great question, Alice.
This being IO, I think Pliant very early on elected to use iResist.
I think that really does allow us flexibility to deal with issues of
pseudoprogression,
to do with
ensuring that we're actually confirming responses, ensuring
that we're actually treating patients, if they're well,
beyond that first progression scan as well, and to actually confirm the disease
progression.
So I do think that that was indeed helpful.
I don't actually know if there was a big difference between
iResist or resist, if we actually did both and did a comparison.
But I think in general, it didn't make that much of a difference, but it did
certainly ensure that all investigators were truly
assessing and managing patients per SITC
guidelines, and it's good that the SITC precedent is right there, waiting to
ask a question later.
We'll start with the first microphone.
I was wondering if you have any serial
biopsies to look into and
whether you see evidence for reduction of TGF-beta or
TGF-beta signaling through SMAD2 and SMAD3.
Yeah, great question. Yes, there were paired tumor
biopsies collected, and a lot of the analysis is ongoing
now. There are plans as well in the current expansion, of course, to learn more
about the underlying biology. I think that's what we will be looking
into as well. But certainly, there was evidence of changes there and
modulation of the target.
And TGF-beta modulation in the patients?
TGF-beta modulation, yes.
So I think that will be looked into.
We didn't have the data to show, but that's something that will be done.
Thank you, team.
Yeah. Thanks so much.
We have time for one last quick question in the middle here.
Thank you for the great presentation, Ilam Karaca from MD Anderson.
I was wondering that if you check for pancreatic cancer also.
Did we treat any pancreatic cancer patients? Was that the question?
Yeah.
I don't think so, yeah, but it would be on the slide if you
go back and listen to me five minutes
back. Yeah, I don't think we had any pancreatic cancer patients on this trial.
That's why I was wondering that.
Yeah.
If it is the case,
do you think that how can we modulate for a pancreatic
cancer also?
I don't see why not, right? Again, the whole principle here
is really inducing,
and reinvigorating, these tumors to really
get them to respond again to immune checkpoint inhibitors.
Thank you.
And I think the key thing here is secondary resistance in these patients.
I think that's the real opportunity in the clinic now with this drug.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Yap.
Thank you very much. Our next speaker will be Marwan Fakhry,
Dr. Marwan Fakhry at City of Hope National Medical Center, and
he will be discussing AMG 355, a
novel anti-CCR8
antibody.
You have to click start at the top.
The top start?
Scroll up to the top, right in the middle there by your name.
No, with the mouse.
All right.
So I'm technology challenged.
Good morning, everyone. It's a pleasure to be here, and thank you to
the co-chairs
and for the committee
for selecting this
abstract for presentation.
So, on behalf of my co-authors and the lead author
who could not make it today, I am presenting the initial
results of a Phase I study of AMG 355,
a novel anti-CCR8 antibody, as a single agent and in
combination with pembrolizumab in patients with solid tumors.
Here are my disclosures.
AMG 355 targets
CCR8, which is selectively enriched in tumors.
We know that intratumor enrichment in CCR8-positive
Tregs is associated with poor prognosis and that Tregs
are associated with immunosuppression.
The panel on the left shows the CCR8 expression in tumor
versus
blood and normal tissue, and you see that other Treg markers,
canonical markers such as CCR4, CTLA4,
CD25, and FoxP3, on the other hand, are expressed across
normal tissue, blood, and tumor.
AMG 355 is a Treg depleting monoclonal
antibody engineered
for enhanced Fc gamma RIIIa binding.
The afucosylated Fc fragment improves
the NK cell bindings, resulting in more efficient
ADCC and therefore Treg depletion.
Here you see pre-clinical data showing in a CT26 model
that the CCR8 depletion in blue
with a CCR8 depleting antibody is associated with clinical activity, while
CCR8 binding without depletion
in red did not have any significant activity.
CCR8 binding with a Treg
depleting antibody through ADCC is associated with
a decrease in CCR8-positive Tregs in the tumor,
but no impact on the expression in spleen and lymph node.
And on the right, you can see in an MC38 model
that the combination with an anti-PD-1 and an
anti-CCR8, specifically a Treg depleting
anti-CCR8, is associated with robust clinical activity with
nine out of ten CRs in an MC38 model.
And this synergistic activity is the
driver for the
hypothesis
for looking at the combination clinically.
So in this Phase I clinical trial,
AMG 355 was evaluated as a monotherapy
or in combination with pembrolizumab.
The top escalation plot shows the monotherapy
escalation starting at a very low dose of 0.28 milligram
all the way up to 700 milligram. It was given intravenously every three
weeks.
The study design was an accelerated escalation
design, initially with one patient per cohort until we hit a Grade 2
toxicity. And once a Grade 2 toxicity is noted, the escalation
goes to three patients minimum per cohort.
Backfill cohorts were also included
starting cohort number six, and those cohorts had mandatory
pre and Cycle 2 biopsies.
On the combination arm, the escalation started at 70 milligrams for
AMG 355, all the way up to 700 milligrams.
To the right, you can see the patient demographics.
Seventy-seven patients were enrolled on this study, 47 on the monotherapy
arm, 30 on the combination.
The histologies that were allowed were colorectal, gastric, non-small
cell lung cancer, and melanoma, with only four patients with melanoma enrolled in
this study. These patients were heavily pretreated with a median number
of therapies of three lines of treatment.
About 40% of patients on this study had prior PD-1 or PD-L1
exposure.
You can see that the CCR8 at baseline by immune positive
score percentage was a median of 5.5
on the monotherapy and four on the combination.
Here we show the safety data. No dose-limiting toxicities were
noted on this study.
The tornado plots to the right show the treatment
emergent adverse events and the treatment-related adverse events to
the right of each plot. The top plot is for the monotherapy arm.
The bottom plot is for the combination arm.
Note that the agent was relatively safe with Grade 3
treatment-related adverse event on the monotherapy arm limited to less than
5% of patients.
One patient with increased LFTs and one patient with diarrhea with Grade 3
toxicities were noted in this cohort.
On the bottom, you can see the tornado plot for the pembrolizumab plus AMG
355.And you can see here that the
more grade three toxicities were noted, but still only about 17% of
patients had grade three toxicities.
Again, those were mostly GI, such as amylase,
lipase,
and there was also lymphopenia, hyperglycemia, and hypoalbuminemia.
Most of the toxicities related to AMG 355 on both arms
were grade one and grade two infusion reactions, as you can see on the top of
each tornado plot, and those were limited to the
day one of cycle one.
Here we show the pharmacokinetics, and I want to note here that
this is a dose-normalized AUC. So if you see
that the plot is the same across all dose level, it indicates
that there is consistency in elimination and dose-related
increase in pharmacokinetics.
Now we move to the efficacy.
Here you see three plots on three different
rows. The first row is for the duration of treatment for
each individual patient, the middle is for the
waterfall plot for the target lesions efficacy, and the third is for
the IPS score for CCR8 expression.
To the left, the three plots show the monotherapy, and to the right, you can
see the combination.
On the monotherapy arm, we see one patient with a partial response.
This is a patient with melanoma who had previously been treated with a PD-1
CTLA-4 therapy with subsequent progression.
This patient, as you can see, had a very durable response.
Note that the stable disease rate on the monotherapy between 70 to
700 milligrams was 19%. There's no strong
correlation that we can say between
the IPS score and response, but note that there was
only one response in this situation.
But we do not see a specific signal with SD either.
On the combination arm, we have one patient with a complete
response. This is a patient with gastric cancer who had
prior nivolumab.
The stable disease rate on the combination arm was 33%.
Here we show the pharmacodynamics on the study
with the CCRA depletion.
To the left, you can see the
monotherapy on the part A and the combination on part B.
And at all dose levels from 70 milligrams to 700
milligrams, you can see robust depletion in CCR8 positive
cells. This applies both for the monotherapy and the combination
arms. And the plot to the right shows the pool
data for all patients who underwent biopsies on this study, with a
robust number of patients undergoing a screening biopsy and a cycle two
biopsy.
Here we show the CCR8 over CD8 ratio with a similar
pattern of reduction in the CCR8 over CD8 ratio, again
suggesting modulation of the tumor microenvironment.
This is an example of immunohistochemistry on a patient
with
melanoma involving the skin, lymph nodes, lung, pancreas, and
with gastric metastases as well. This patient was treated with
pembrolizumab for three years with the best response, with partial response with
subsequent progression, and started AMG 355 monotherapy at 70
milligram Q3 weeks at a partial response, and that's the patient I
pointed
to on the waterfall plots. You can see
substantial reduction in CCR8 positive cells on
cycle number two compared to cycle number one.
On the other hand, subject number two is a patient with colorectal cancer with
also substantial reduction in CCR8 positivity on cycle
number two compared to screening.
However, this patient, who had previously progressed after FOLFIRINOX and
FOLFIRI, had progression on the first imaging after
initiation of AMG 355 with progressive disease.
So to conclude, AMG 355 was safe
and tolerable at doses up to 700 milligrams, but
clinical activity as a single agent or in combination with pembrolizumab
was limited.
Paired biopsy data supports pharmacodynamic activity of AMG
355 with a decrease in CCR8 seen, as well as a
decrease in CCR8 over CD8 ratio in most
subjects on treatment, suggesting modulation of the tumor
microenvironment on this study.
Additional tissue-based multiomics spatial analyses are planned in a
subset of paired biopsies to further characterize changes in the tumor
microenvironment, including immune cell profiles. Thank you.
I would just like to thank the patients, their families, and
caregivers, and all investigators.
Special thanks to the AMG 355 team across Amgen Research and
Development. This study was sponsored by Amgen. Thanks.
Thank you very much. It looks like we have a question coming from the middle
microphone.
Can you say a little bit more about how the CCR8 scoring
was done? In particular,
did you also look at FoxP3,
since not all
Treg cells are... While CCR8 is very
selective
for Treg cells relative to other T cells in
the tumor,
not all Treg cells are CCR8 positive.
Yeah, no, excellent question. So the IPS score was
basically based on the percentage of immune cells per field
of view, and a minimum of four fields of views were
used on this study and up to 12, and if there's not enough, it was also allowed to
be expanded.
So that's how the IPS score was
basically derived.And I don't have
full data on FOXP3 yet. In general,
the initial data we have suggests that
intratumorally there's also some reduction in FOXP3,
but that work is still ongoing,
so further details will come.
Go to that side.
Yeah. So fascinating data.
Question on the patient that had the partial response.
That patient clearly benefited from pembrolizumab for
three years.
Number one, how recently was the pembro given?
Because could the secondary response, could that have been a
combo effect? And how many other patients did you have with
secondary resistance that had an immune checkpoint inhibitor within the
last three months?
I do not have the data on the recent exposure
on the PD-1.
I think there was a mix of patients who just jumped from immunotherapy
into, and others who did not, but I don't have that data.
I have to get back with you on that particular patient with melanoma.
Thank you.
But the reality is 40% of the patients were pre-treated
with PD-1 therapy. So, still the response rates are
low.
Yeah.
That microphone.
Hey, excuse me.
It was rather interesting that there was a lack of immune-related
adverse events.
Could you share your thoughts on whether or not this may be due
to the ADCC-dependent mechanism of
action opposed to direct depletion?
And in individuals that did not respond, were their tumors
lacking in NK cells?
Yeah. So, in general, the mechanism
is supposed to be associated with lower adverse events.
This is an evolving field. There are other CCR8
depleting antibodies that have been associated with a higher rate of
adverse events, and some that have been associated also
with some depletion in Tregs peripherally.
So,
I don't know that we have the answer as to why we
had lower adverse events on this study and if that would
be something that correlates also with a lower activity or not.
But
I think more data will be needed from other compounds as well to have
cross-comparisons. I do not have the data on the NK
cells or the spatial analysis yet, and
that's work in progress.
Yeah. That'll be very interesting to addressing some of those issues. Thank you.
We'll go to the middle microphone.
So more globally, CCR8 depleting antibodies have been in the
clinic for over five years.
Some have shown greater anti-tumor activity than what we saw here, but
none have advanced to later stage clinical trials.
Do you have any thoughts on what is going on in the field?
Actually, I think the LM108 compound, to my
knowledge, is in second line phase three clinical trial.
In China, but-
In China
...as far as global trials.
Not in the US. I think we have to be data-driven, and I think I share
your concern. The response rate here is/ are
not robust, and whether this is agent-dependent
or this is of concern to the class in general,
remains to be seen. I do believe that there may be some differences between
different agents as far as efficacy, as we have seen higher
response rates from other reports.
But,
I don't think we have seen enough published data or reported data to support
moving to phase three. At least I have not in the United States.
Any next steps for this molecule?
There are no next steps that I am aware of, but that's an Amgen
question.
Okay. This will be our last question. Go ahead.
Nice presentation. I'm Maryam Bolouei Baghlou, a postdoctoral fellow from
Northwestern University.
So I understand that CCR8 is enriched on
intratumoral Tregs. But given that it's not
exclusively expressed on Tregs, did you confirm that the
anti-tumor efficacy seen is exclusively due to
Treg depletion?
Yeah.
I'm sorry, what did you say? The mechanism is exclusively due to the Treg-
Yeah. Because
given that it's not exclusively expressed on
only Treg population, some other
minor immune subpopulations may also express
CCR8. So did you confirm that the efficacy
seen is due to intratumoral Treg depletion?
Did you confirm that?
The reality, we haven't really seen that much efficacy except for two
cases, and I think at this point, mechanistically, it's hard to tell why
these two patients responded.
So the big question in my mind is why it did not work in
general, rather than why it worked in these two patients.
Thank you.
Thank you, Doctor.
Next up, Dr. Alice Chen at the NCI, Division
of Cancer Treatment and Diagnosis, presenting safety of prolonged checkpoint
inhibitor exposure in alveolar soft part sarcoma patients.
I want to thank upfront the patients, their family, my
investigators, NCI, CTAP, and
Genentech, and the organizing committee for making it possible for
me to be here to present the safety of prolonged ICI use in a
very rare tumor called alveolar soft part sarcoma.
I have no financial disclosures, but the NCI does have CRADA
agreements with Genentech and AstraZeneca in relation to my
clinicAnd any opinions that I expressed here are
those of my own and not those of the federal government.
So ICI use at this point mostly has been limited to up
to two years, and this is probably from early trial design
versus the biology.
Recently, data's starting to come out that overall survival
benefits beyond two years, there may not be any,
and that
this has occurred in most commonly what we've seen in melanoma and
non-small cell lung cancer.
Also, one of the important issues is late onset
toxicity.
Melanoma, when it's been reported, has noted that there's
really no new late onset toxicities
versus in one report of non-small cell lung cancer, there
50% of the patients had reported
immune-related adverse events beyond the two years mark,
mostly dermatologic, gastrointestinal, and
musculoskeletal.
However, in sarcoma there's very limited data, but
recently, both in undifferentiated pleomorphic
sarcoma and ASPS, ICI has shown activity in
this population. These tumors tend to occur in young
patients, and so long-term toxicity is extremely
important in order to assess the need for how long to treat
these patients for.
To address this gap, we looked at our data from our phase two trial of
atezolizumab in ASPS patients, and we looked at
patients who's treated beyond cycle 34, which is the two years
mark.
So what is alveolar soft part sarcoma?
It's extremely rare sarcoma that occurs in less than 1%
of all soft tissue sarcomas.
It has a very indolent growth pattern.
Most patients present it because they're young, very active, they notice a
lump in their extremity or trunk, and they relate it to some
trauma. However, ultimately they will seek attention.
Most of the tumors are resected upfront as management,
but this tumor has a very high metastatic potential
and can recur very late after resection,
usually will occur in the lung, CNS, or bone.
It is characterized by ASPSCR1,
CFE3 fusion proteins.
There are two specific types, type one and type two.
In our study, actually, most of our patient had type one.
Did that make a difference? It's not clear.
Our study
treated patients down to the age of two and up.
We gave them atezolizumab every three weeks.
They could not have had prior ICI, so this would be their first
exposure to it.
Patients we had collected blood as well as tissue,
and we imaged patients every three cycles, and that goes further out
the longer they stay on study. If patients
progress, adult patients are allowed to go on
atezolizumab/bevacizumab combinations.
If patient has stable disease or better at two years mark,
they were given the option of staying on treatment
or starting a drug holiday.
If they go on the drug holiday, they were scanned every three month.
The intent is that during that two years of drug holiday, if their tumor
recurs, they were given the option to resume
atezolizumab.
At the end of two-year drug holiday, we weren't clear what to do at that point.
We actually amended the study to follow patients
every six month with scans to see if they had recurred.
This was a early therapeutic clinical trial network study.
It took a lot of sites for us to accrue the patients that we
did for this rare tumor.
We were very successful in it.
The single-arm study with atezolizumab given at 1,200
milligrams for adults, 15 milligrams per kilogram for
children.
Radiation is allowed for painful lesions or
CNS mets after the second cycle if the initial
CNS met was asymptomatic at the time of diagnosis.
iResist was used as a secondary endpoint for this study.
The primary endpoint was to look at the response rate,
and we also, secondary endpoint, looked at immuno-oncology
biomarkers in paired tumor biopsies.
The Summers plot on the left-hand side
showed the
response rates at 37%, and this is presented
in "The New England Journal" in 2023.
Because of this study, atezolizumab is now the standard of
care and is FDA approved. NCCN guideline
has been updated.
What we don't know still is how long to treat patients and how
safe is it to go past the two years mark.
So we actually updated and will be reporting, published
at 4:00 PM today at JCO, the three-year follow-up study.
During that process, we also looked at those patients who were treated past
the two years mark to look at toxicity issues.
Seventeen out of 54 patients went past the two years mark in terms of
treatment with atezolizumab. The ages were 11 to
56, median was 29.
Twelve patients were on monotherapy of atezolizumab and did
not cross over. Five patients had atezolizumab upon
progression, had atezolizumab/bevacizumab.
The total, the highest number of cycles delivered was 124 cycles.
Three out of 17 patients had new onset of grade two/three
toxicity after cycle
34One had grade 2 hypertension
and proteinuria after starting bevacizumab, and it's not clear that this
is immune-related versus toxicity to bevacizumab.
One had grade 3 AST that resolved without any change in therapy,
and one had grade 2 pruritus at cycle 47.
At cycle 49, she went on a drug holiday.
But with symptomatic management, patient did resolve all symptoms after
five months.
There was no grade four or five toxicity, and no patients came off
study because of these adverse events.
This is the swimmer's plot for those 17 patients.
As you know, patient 15 had respiratory infection
at the start and had the AST elevation.
Patient 39 had um, the proteinuria,
had thyroid issues at the start of the treatment,
and then patient six had allergic rhinitis that had the pruritus.
In conclusion, treatment duration and the risk of irreversible
toxicities are key consideration in patients who have
plateau response to treatment on ICI,
especially the AYA population.
Though the numbers are small reported here, prolonged
atezolizumab is feasible and safe
from our study.
Late toxicity appears less frequently than those reported in non-small
cell lung cancer. The question is: is this related to age, since
ours was 29, and the case reports or the
manuscript that I reported for non-small cell lung cancer, their median age was
greater than 60.
Hopefully, the data presented here in the JCO article this
afternoon talking about the drug holiday will provide information
for patients at the two years mark for their ICI therapy who
have discussion with their oncologist regarding what may be the best treatment
option for them at that point.
I want to thank all of my investigators, patients, and their family for
making it possible to present this data. Thank you.
Thank you. Please feel free to come up to the microphones for questions in the
room, and please speak into the microphone.
And I will also moderate questions from the chat.
So given the small cohort and histology-specific nature of your study, how should
clinicians balance the apparent safety of prolonged atezolizumab use with the
uncertainty around long-term irreversible toxicities, especially in young
adults?
So I think given the data did not show any unexpected new
late adverse events, and that in terms of
patients tolerating treatment well, I think that it is reasonable for patients
and their oncologists to really discuss these options, and that the good
news is they do have two options. What is unanswered at this point to help make
that decision is what happens to patient on drug holiday if they
progressed retreatment with atezolizumab.
Unfortunately, we did not have that data even from our study to be able to
answer that. Hopefully, real-world data will be able to answer
some of that down the road.
Great. Thank you.
Another question.
So there's a relatively low incidence reported in late onset
adverse events beyond the two-year mark, and how do you see this influencing future
trial designs as well as guidelines for fixed duration versus
indefinite checkpoint inhibitors?
I think it's important to consider biomarkers that may help
answer the question of would patient benefit from further
treatment,
which is something that we
don't have an answer to right now, to really consider that in terms of future
trial designs
to
know if they will benefit from deriving further or if they go on drug
holiday, the potential of restarting treatment for them.
I think that would be a very interesting question to try to answer.
Indeed. Thank you. Well, thank you very much, Dr.
Chan-
Thank you
... for your presentation.
Okay, we'll now go on to our next presentation, which is
Dr. Giralda, who will be presenting on
DKY709
alone or in combination with PDR001.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank you for the committee
for selecting this abstract. It's really an
honor to present on behalf of all ARCO investigators the Phase I
study of DKY709, an IKZF2
degrader alone and in combination with PDR001, a
BD1 inhibitor.
These are my disclosures.
So DKY709 is an orally administered molecular glue
degrader of IKZF2, also known as Helios, a
transcription factor of the Ikaros family expressed in regulatory T
cells.
So DKY709 mediates degradation of
IKZF2, sparing IKZF1 and
3 by binding to the Celeplon complex and recruiting
IKZF2 for ubiquitination and proteasome-mediated
degradation.
In vitro, DKY709 led to reduced T-rex
suppressive function and enhanced effector T cell cytokine
production. In vivo, in mouse models with a humanized
immune system, IKZF degradation by
DKY709 modulated intratumoral T-rex and
resulted in tumor growth inhibition.
This led to the Phase I study result that
we are presenting today, studying DKY709 both in
monotherapy and in combination with spartalisumab.
In this slide, you can see the study design.
This was a global Phase I study. It included two
parts in escalation, a monotherapy escalation and a combination
escalation.Patients with non-small cell lung cancer and melanoma
were included. All patients with these histologies had progressed on previous
checkpoint inhibitors. We also included patients with nasopharyngeal
carcinoma that had progressed upon standard treatment.
We started with a dose of 20 milligrams continuous dosing, and we
escalated up to 40. We then reduced to 10, six,
and four. We also explored intermittent schedules of two
weeks on and three weeks on and one off of both 10 and 20
milligrams. The presentation here today focuses on data
that mostly includes patients coming from the single
agent and combination part of the dose escalation part of the study, which
were guided by a Bayesian hierarchical logistic regression model.
The primary endpoint was safety and tolerability.
Key secondary were PK/PD and preliminary activity.
As of data cutoff, 58 patients were treated with
DKY-709 monotherapy,
30 melanoma, 24 non-small cell, and four nasopharyngeal
carcinoma.
Thirty-one of the population was Asian.
All patients were ECOG zero or one, and it was a heavily pretreated
population with a median prior lines of three for melanoma and
non-small cell and 4.5 for nasopharyngeal carcinoma.
We treated 40 patients in the combination, 12 melanoma,
15 non-small cell, and 13 nasopharyngeal carcinoma.
Fifty-five percent of the population was Asian.
Most of the patients had ECOG zero or one, and the median prior
lines was two for melanoma and non-small cell and three for
nasopharyngeal carcinoma.
PK-wise, the drug behaved very well.
It was a fast absorption with a medium Tmax of one to two hours
and a dose proportional exposure increase.
We reached PK steady state before cycle one, day 15, and there was a
small mean accumulation ranging from 2.1 to 2.7
with an effective half-life of 26 to 35 hours.
There was only modest PK variability, and the PK in
combination really appeared comparable to the one in single
agent.
In the periphery, we really observed robust IKs set
degradation in CD4 positive FoxP3 positive T cells.
And you can see in the slide flow cytometry data showing
IKZF2 degradation in CD4 positive FoxP3
positive Tregs at all tested doses.
And these are individual patients that are represented in the slide with a
cycle one, day one and cycle one, day 15 below.
If we pool the data, we observed more than 90% reduction in
the CD4 positive FoxP3 positive IKZF2 positive cells
with all doses above six milligrams.
This was also translated in the tumor biopsies, and we also saw
consistent IKZF2 degradation in the tumor
biopsies. You can see on the left the reduction of CD45
positive IKZF2 positives across all dose levels,
although there was no clear dose dependency or relation with response.
And at the right side, you can see a beautiful example of IKZF2
degradation in CD45 positive T cells
by fluoromunohistochemistry in a patient with non-small cell lung
cancer that had a partial response treated with DKY at 40
milligrams, and we will be speaking later about her.
But you can see that there's really a decrease in the purple and also on
the yellow due to the partial response.
Here you can see the safety profile with all patients at the right
side. The most common treatment-related adverse events were
myalgia and fatigue for the monotherapy, 19% each,
followed by QTc prolongation. It's important to notice
that we observed a composite peripheral neuropathy
signal based on related adverse event terms, and this happened in
28% of patients. We had three DLTs,
a grade three peripheral sensory neuropathy, a grade three
myalgia, and a grade three skin rash.
In combination, we also observed dose-dependent adverse events.
The most common treatment-related adverse events were rash, diarrhea,
and ALT increase, each at 22.5% of cases.
We also observed the same composite peripheral neuropathy signal
based on related adverse event terms that happened in up to 30%
of cases. We also had two dose-limiting toxicities in the
combination, a grade two/three pain in extremity, and a
grade three meningitis and an encephalitis.
So if we dive a bit deeper into the neuropathy and QTc
prolongation, we observed that more patients experienced neuropathy
at doses above 10 milligrams, and that below six
milligrams,
we didn't have any grade three events.
Neuropathy in general was reversible and manageable with neuropathic
medications, but it did require dose interruptions and dose
reductions.
Similarly, the risk of QTc prolongation increased with
DKY-709 dose.
However, at doses below 10 milligrams, the mean QTc increase
was less than 15 milliseconds.
Activity-wise, DKY-709 displayed
monotherapy anti-tumor activity.
We had three partial responses, two confirmed partial responses in
melanoma, and one complete response in a melanoma patient and one
confirmed partial response in a non-small cell.
And we must remember these were all IO pretreated patients.
The disease control rate was of 31.4%.
There was also activity in the combination, and we had three
partial responses, two in melanoma and one in non-small cell lung
cancer patients, and these were all IO pretreated patients.
There were also observed two partial responses in patients with
immunotherapy-naive nasopharyngeal carcinoma.The disease control
rate was 37.5.
These responses were durable, and you can see in the swimmer
plot that 18 patients remained on treatment for more than six
months with a response of SD, partial response, or
complete response.
And to conclude, I'll show you two vignettes of two patients included in the
study. The patient on the left, it's a patient treated in
Memorial by Dr. Awad. She's a 66-year-old female
patient with a non-small cell cancer patient with a PD-L1 of
50%. Now it's the mystery of... Well, you're going to have to
believe me.
You're going to have to believe me.
You can see there, she had a partial response that lasted for two months,
and this patient had to discontinue treatment due to toxicity.
The patient at the right was treated at our site, so I can handle better if there's
no slide. She was a 66-year-old female patient that had
progressed to nivolumab and also a phase one study with a TRR
agonist and nivolumab. She started on six milligrams QD, and
this patient had to change dose also due to neuropathy.
This patient had a confirmed complete response, and we had her on
treatment for over two years, and then due to the
neuropathy and also that we performed a PET scan that was negative, we decided to
stop her on treatment, and she's still with a complete response.
This patient also developed a vitiligo, a very big
vitiligo while she was on study.
So to conclude, DKY709 really showed good
PK properties. It robustly degraded
IKSF2 in peripheral regulatory T cells and
also in tumor-infiltrated lymphocytes in the paired biopsies.
The most common treatment-related adverse events were myalgia and fatigue,
and rash diarrhea and ALT increase for the combination.
We did observe dose-dependent reversible peripheral neuropathy
in 28% of the cases in monotherapy and 30% in the
combination, and a risk of QTC prolongation increasing with
dose.
DKY709 showed evidence for clinical activity,
both as single agent and in combination, in patients that had already
progressed to checkpoint inhibitors.
The recommended dose was six milligrams QD, both for monotherapy
and for combination. So to conclude,
DKY709 showed a favorable PK/PD, manageable
toxicity, and meaningful antitumor activity alone and in
combination with PDR001. And with this, I want to
conclude by thanking patients, families, all personnel involved in the
study, our study sponsor, Novartis, and everybody for your attention.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for an excellent presentation and masterfully managing when the
screens went out. It looks like everything is back now.
So
feel free to come up to the microphones to ask questions.
I'm just waiting to see if... Yeah, we do have one question here.
Hi. Thank you for the great talk. Question, would you comment on the
adverse event on the peripheral neuropathy?
Is there
IKSF2's role that lead to that? Have
you investigated that?
Well, we really observed it consistently
throughout the clinical trial. As I said, it
was described in different ways. So there was from pain
in extremity to peripheral neuropathy.
So we really believe it was something to do with the drug, and
it was drug related, and it did
solve really very well
with the dose interruptions and dose reductions.
About the physiopathological mechanisms, I cannot go
into it, but it was clearly related to the drug.
Thank you.
Just to clarify, do you anticipate that being from Treg
depletion an anticipated response, or specific to the drug, or just hard to know at
this point in development?
Well,
Treg
depletion and Treg modulation has been challenging.
We were hearing on the previous presentation.
But to my knowledge, the neuropathy in this way has
not been observed by Treg depletion per se.
So I think it's a bit of a different toxicity profile
from other Treg depleters in the field.
Thank you very much. Middle microphone.
Yeah. Which E3 ligase does the GLU target?
I think it's the three.
What's that?
Three.
What did you ask? Sorry.
Which E3 ligase? Does it target to cereblon?
To cereblon, yes.
It is. Okay.
E3, I think it is.
And just in FOB, so,
do you see a change in numbers of Tregs?
Just simple stuff with this drug.
If we observe changes in Tregs in the tumor?
In numbers of Tregs, either in the periphery or, I don't know if you have
tumor biopsies.
Yes, we did.
And they were decreased?
They were decreased.
Okay. A lot, a little?
This much?
I don't have the data, so I cannot give you that data. Yeah.
Okay.
Go over to this microphone.
Hi. Thank you for the nice talk. So,
Helios is an intracellular factor, so how do you
access this factor inside the cell?
How do you internalize the antibody in the cell?
So the preclinical, if I understood correctly, all the
preclinical work of this compound was already published a couple of years ago, and
there you can see all of the description.
It's on the first reference of the slide.
Thank you.
We'll go over to that.
Yeah, great presentation. In terms of the Tregs that you're
seeing, do you see any reprogramming of those Tregs in terms of
induction of effector cytokines?
To be honest, I don't have that data.
I'm sure Novartis is looking into it
Okay, great. Well, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Next up, I'd like to introduce Dr. Kim from the Division of Medical Oncology,
Yonsei Cancer Centre, presenting a Phase 2 study of tislelizumab plus
investigational agents as first-line treatment in recurrent and/or
metastatic head and neck squamous cell carcinoma.
Hello, everyone. I'm Hyeryoun Kim, the medical
oncologist in Yonsei Cancer Center in Seoul, Korea.
I'd like to thank the scientific committee for
selecting our study for this presentation.
On behalf of my colleague, I'm going to
present a Phase 2 study on the PD-1
inhibitor, the tislelizumab, combined with
investigational agent as
a first-line treatment for recurrent or metastatic
head and neck cancer patient.
Here is my disclosure.
So
head and neck cancer accounted for
almost 900,000 new cancer cases, and there are
450,000 deaths worldwide. And even though
the use of anti-PD-1 and PD-L1 monotherapy,
including pembrolizumab and nivolumab in head and neck cancer,
not all patients experience durable response or
prolonged survival outcomes. Therefore, there
is an unmet need for novel treatment combination.
The tislelizumab is PD-1 and PD-L1
blockade,
some result in the T cell activation.
Cirgelicimab is an anti-TIM-3 monoclonal antibody
blocking the binding of the post peptide setting to TIM-3,
while concomitantly inducing TIM-3
internalization. Arcetuzumab,
LBA-007, is an anti-LAG3 monoclonal
antibody effectively block the binding of LAG3 to
its ligand, including MHage-2 molecules and others.
The finally to prevent the inhibitory signal by
LAG3 on T cells.
Our study explored tislelizumab anti-PD-L1 monoclonal
antibody combined with the cirgelicimab
or anti-TIM-3 antibody and arcetuzumab
anti-LAG3 antibody. These agent target
a distinct
immune checkpoint to explore enhanced
efficacy in our patient.
Looking at the study design, this Phase 2
randomized open label trial evaluate the
tislelizumab with or without cirgelicimab and the
LBA-007 for the first-line treatment
in patient with recurrent or metastatic head and neck cancer
patient. The key eligibility criteria is
patient with squamous cell cancer, oropharynx and oral
cavity and hypopharynx or larynx, and recurrent or
metastatic disease incurable by local
treatment. PD-L1 expression level is
CPS more than one, and there was no other
prior checkpoint inhibitor treatment and ECOG
status zero or one. These patients were
randomized into these four arms,
each with 40 patient and total patient
160 patients was enrolled in this trial.
Arm A was tislelizumab monotherapy.
Arm B was tislelizumab plus cirgelicimab
anti-TIM-3 blockade. Arm C was tislelizumab
with LBA-007, LAG3 inhibitor.
Arm D was a triple combination.
The randomization was stratified by these factors:
PD-L1 expression level, a low express of one to
19 and high express of more than 20/20.
The primary
endpoint
was confirmed objective response rate by investigator.
The secondary endpoint was PFS and duration of response
or and so forth.
This is a baseline demographics.
Demographics were consistently across all
the treatment group. They're reflecting our
target head and neck population. The 80% of
patients were male and 70%
of patients were Asian. The primary disease
location, including oral cavity, oropharynx and larynx, and
hypopharynx, with oral cavity being the most
prevalent site, encompassing almost
42% of patients. The 20% of
patient was HPV positive, and 60% of
patients have previously received their
platinum-based chemotherapy in local regional treatment
setting.
How are the result?
The objective response rate of
27.5 was reported in tislelizumab
monotherapy,
and the similar confirmed objective response rate were
observed across all the treatment arm.
They ranged from 25% to
27.5% in each group.
How are the disease control rate with tislelizumab monotherapy
was 55%, and the disease control rate was
numerically higher in doubletAnd the
triple combination treatment.
Looking at this waterfall plot, as shown in
this plot, the comparable objective response rate was
observed across the different treatment combination.
Importantly,
we observed the three patients in arm C and the
two patient in arm D achieved complete
response in this clinical trial.
Arm C and D are group with anti-LAG3
blockade.
I'd like to highlight the subgroup analysis data.
This slide show the median progression-free
survival and the objective response rate
according to the PD-L1 expression level, PD-L1
CPS more than 20 and 1 to 19 subgroup
analysis.
For the patients with PD-L1 low expression,
CPS 1 to 19, our study finding that
a combination with cemiplimab or
AVL007 achieved the numerically
longer median PFS. The range of
the
monotreatment is 1.4 months, and the
cemiplimab combination is 5.4 months, and the
AVL007 is 4.1 months, and triple is
4.1 months, and numerically higher than
tislelizumab monotreatment.
And in contrast, the patient with PD-L1
high expression level more than 20, the tislelizumab
monotreatment arm show the median
progression-free survival as much as 8.1 months,
and the objective response rate is
44.4 months. There was no additive
efficacy benefit in other combination group.
Looking at the safety profile, each treatment
arms were well tolerated and toxicity
observed were manageable, demonstrating the promising
safety profile. The most common treatment
emergent AE, including the anemia
and hypothyroidism and the AST elevation.
The most are grade one or two.
The immune-mediated AE occurred in
35% of the patient overall population.
Infusion related reaction occurred in
7% of patient overall population.
Our findings suggest that the combination therapy have
favorable safety profile. There was no additive
toxicity profile issues in the combination treatment.
So in conclusion, for patients with recurrent or
metastatic head and neck cancer, the efficacy was
comparable across all the treatment arm.
Adding cergemetinib and/or AVL007 to
tislelizumab as a first-line treatment did not show
the additional benefit overall.
In subgroup analysis, patient with PD-L1 low
expression, CPS 1 to 19,
combination with TIM-3 and/or LAG-3 blockade show
the numerically additive effect compared with
tislelizumab monotreatment. However, we should be
cautious interpreted because a lack of statistical
significance in those patient.
Finally, safety profile with tislelizumab
monotreatment or with doublet or triplet
combination treatment were well tolerable and
manageable, and they are consistent with
previous report with immune checkpoint
inhibitors treatment.
Finally, I'd like to thank the patient and their
family members and all the investigators and
co-investigator and study teams
at each site of participating center.
This study was sponsored by ViroPharma,
and I'd like to thank all the
audience for their attention
on my talk. Thank you for your attention.
Again, for questions in the room, please come up to the microphones and speak into
the microphone.
And I'll moderate questions from online.
So what is the potential explanation for why the tislelizumab based combination did
not have greater efficacy than the monotherapy group?
Yeah. Is this question?
Mm-hmm.
Yes.
Yeah. So I think that
this is the tough question, and why the combination
treatment did not show any
efficacies even in the combination treatment
in this trial.
I think that this trial enrolled the patient with
CPS more than one. So these patients are
very heterogeneous patient. So in those
patient, half of patient is PD-L1 more than 20,
and the other half of patients are 1 to
19. So as subgroup analysis,
the patients with CPS more than 20 is very
hard tumor. So maybe the PD-L1 monotreatment is
enough, and the PD-L1
pathway is dominant pathway for the immune
suppression in tumor microenvironment in those
patients.However, some patients with
CPS 1 to 19, some adding this
another immune checkpoint blockade would be additive
the effect in those patients. So in these
patients is mix of the CPS 1 to
19 and the CPS more than 20%. So
I think that some mix of data can
dilute the patient with combination treatment.
So I think that in the near future, some more
development of immune checkpoint inhibitor.
So I think that we should focusing on the
enitched group for
have some potential to
increasing the efficacies in the
immune checkpoint blockade double or triple combination.
Great, thank you. And microphone one.
Thank you for your presentation. In the background you introduced that
the reason you looked for this study was that the
monotherapy with anti PD-1, PD-L1 was not
good enough to benefit many patients, so you looked
for different combinations. But you ended up saying that
they didn't add any benefit compared to monotherapy
with tislelizumab. So my question is, do you aim to
compare the monotherapy with this tislelizumab to other
anti PD-1 and anti PD-L1 antibodies such as pembrolizumab
and nivolumab?
Yes, I think that is a good question.
The tislelizumab is PD-1 blockade and there is some
currently in the head and neck cancer based on the
KEYNOTE-048 and the PD-1
pembrolizumab monotreatment is labeled and
approved in the patient with PD-L1 CPS more than one.
So
I think that this is very cautious because this is not just head to head
comparison is not performed. However,
based on the PD-1 pembrolizumab data, the CPS more
than 20,
some objective response rate around the 20%.
So in the
study, the tislelizumab monotreatment in the CPS
more than 20 group is
the objective response rate 27. I
think that this is some comparable data with
another pembrolizumab and nivolumab with
tislelizumab monotreatment in this study.
Thank you.
And next question.
Hi. Thank you so much. Did you guys see any
differences when comparing HPV negative to HPV positive
patients with any of the combination therapies?
Sorry?
Sorry, is this better?
Yeah, it's all right.
Did you all see any marked differences between patients who were HPV
positive versus HPV negative for any of the combination therapies?
Yeah. So
finally, so maybe that we have some interim data
about the efficacies of some progression
free survival and the objective response rate in the HPV
positive and negative patients. So, as you
know, the HPV positive is very favorable
prognostic factors in those setting.
And based on the interim data so far,
there was no big differences of the HPV positive and
negative in the patients, even
according to
some
treatment arm. So currently, I think that in
the HPV factor is prognostic factors,
and this is not predictive factor in the combination or the
treatment arm in our cohort.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you. And we're at time, so we'll save additional questions for after.
Thank you, Dr. Kim.
Thank you.
And for the last talk of the session,
Dr.
Di Giacomo will be discussing 10-year survival and cell-free
DNA methylation from
a trial of asymptomatic brain metastasis with nivolumab plus ipilimumab.
Thank you so much.
Good morning, everybody. I need my presentation that I don't
see.
Ah, we don't have the-
Okay.
There.
Thank you so much.
Okay. Again, good morning. Thank you to the scientific committee for the
opportunity to share on behalf of my co-author results from the
10-year survival and cell-free DNA methylation profiling of
melanoma patients with asymptomatic brain metastasis treated with
the anti CTL4 ipilimumab and anti PD-1 nivolumab in the
multicenter phase 3 INHIBIT 10-2 trial.
My disclosures.
Our previous phase 2 Italian Network for Tumor Biotherapy,
INHIBIT 1 trial firstly reported the activity of the anti CTL4
ipilimumab and the alkylating drugs for temozolomide in a subset
of patients with active untreated metastatic melanoma patient with brain
metastasis, with an interesting overall survival rate at three year
of 28%. Two subsequent phase 2 study, the
CheckMate 204 and the ABC trial reported intracranial
objective responses in more than 50% of patients with
asymptomatic brain metastasis, but treated with anti CTL4
ipilimumab and the anti PD-1 nivolumab.Our Phase
III NIBITANTO study showed a 43 overall
survival rate at the primary analysis at four year and a
subsequent seven-year update in the
same patient population with untreated asymptomatic brain
metastasis, treated again with the anti-CTLA-4 ipilimumab and
anti-PD-1 nivolumab. In spite of the
very impressive results in very hard-to-treat patient population with active
asymptomatic brain metastasis, no biomarker have been identified yet to
select patient population, and in part also due to
the limited accessibility of brain metastasis.
So with this in mind, we have tried to identify potential
biomarker to select patient with an accessible
modality. And today, I will present the final analysis of
the Phase III NIBITANTO study at 10 year, with
its correlation with cell-free DNA profiles.
The NIBITANTO study is a Phase III randomized multicenter studies
led and conceived by the NIBIT Foundation.
The main inclusion criteria were metastatic melanoma patient with active
and treated asymptomatic brain metastasis with a maximum diameter of two
centimeter.
No prior systemic therapy for metastatic disease was allowed.
Among the exclusion criteria,
active brain metastasis, symptomatic leptomeningeal
diseases, but also ocular melanoma and autoimmune diseases.
Patient were randomized to receive in the control arm for the mustardine
or ipilimumab and fuiomustine or ipilimumab and nivolumab.
The primary endpoint was the objective response rate as a median and
overall survival rate. I will present today the 10-year update.
Among the secondary endpoint, intracranial and global
PFS, but also among the exploratory endpoint, and this
thanks to the serial collection of PBMC and plasma samples from
this patient, tumor fraction and tumor specific methylation
score in cell-free DNA will be also reported.
Looking at the patient disposition, 23 patient in
arm A, 26 patient in arm B, and 27 patient in arm
C
were assigned and received respectively fuiomustine, ipilimumab and
fuiomustine, or ipilimumab and nivolumab.
At the time of the analysis, no patients are still on treatment, and all
this patient population were included in this analysis.
Looking at the patient demographics were balanced among
the arms.
Majority of these patient have an ECOG performance status of 0/1,
more than three brain lesions with a maximum diameter of two
centimeter in the majority of patients.
A few patients that were previously treated as a local treatment with surgery
or radiotherapy.
At the data cutoff of December 1st, 2025, we had a median follow-up of
125 months. The 10-year overall survival rate
was 32% for the ipilimumab, nivolumab
arm, as compared with 30% in the fuiomustine arm, and
7% in the ipilimumab fuiomustine arm with a hazard ratio of
0.47.
Looking at the melanoma specific survival, at 10 year, we have
36% of patients alive in the ipilimumab, nivolumab arm, as
compared with 13% and 7%, suggesting the
long-term benefit of this therapeutic combination in this population of patients.
Looking at the secondary endpoint, the global PFS analysis
shows, and you can see that 20% of patients are still alive without global
progression in the ipilimumab, nivolumab arm as compared with
7% in arm B and 4% in arm C.
Importantly, looking at the intracranial progression-free survival, you can see
that 29% of patients are still alive and without intracranial
progression in the ipilimumab and nivolumab arm as compared with
7% and 4%, suggesting that this combination
also able to reduce the risk of brain progression.
But let me show you initial results of the exploratory endpoint looking
at cell-free DNA landscape.
We have collected at baseline from 57 patient
plasma samples and on treatment at week 12
from 29 patient paired plasma samples.
After cell-free DNA isolation, a tumor fraction and tumor specific
methylation score were assessed.
First of all, we have reported a significantly higher median overall survival
in patients with TF, in particular with the t-methylation
score below the baseline median values.
Looking at the potential differences between these two
biomarker at baseline across study arm, you can see that
no significant differences were reported in t-methylation score
across arm
A, B, and C.
However, patient with the TF and tmet score
below the median at baseline were enriched in arm C and had
also the longest overall survival.
Lastly, and looking also at the potential modulation of these two
biomarker during treatment, at week 12, we have reported
a decrease of TF and tmet
score at week 12 in patient with
an overall survival above the median value.
So in conclusion, the 10-year results of the NIBITANTO
study with the longest follow-up available today in this patient population of
patient with asymptomatic, untreated, and active brain
metastasis continue to show persistent long term, the combination
of ipilimumab and nivolumab in a sizable proportion of patients.
With a median follow-up of 125 months, the 10-year overall
survival and the melanoma specific survival rate for the
ipilimumab, nivolumab arm was 32% and 36%
respectively.Median global and intracranial
PFS for the ipilimumab nivolumab arm was 8.7
months with an intracranial PFS rate of
29%.
Looking at the exploratory endpoint, a significantly higher median overall survival
was reported in patients with a TMMET score and tumor fraction
below their median value.
Moreover, patients with a TMMET score and tumor fraction below the
median were enriched in the ipilimumab and nivolumab arm, and that's
also the longest overall survival.
However, a decrease in TMMET score and a tumor fraction was also
reported during treatment at week 12 in patients
with an overall survival above the median.
So overall, these results suggested that
plasma-derived TMMET score and tumor fraction seems to
represent a surrogate biomarker predicting long-term survival in patients
treated with ipilimumab, nivolumab, and asymptomatic brain
metastases.
So I would like to thank all my co-authors, the patients, their families, Bristol
Myers Squibb for their support, and of course, all of you for your attention.
Thank you so much.
I would like to remind people with questions to come up to the microphone.
Maybe I will get started.
Do you have a correlate in the tumor for your plasma methylation
score? Like, does that correlate with anything in the tumor, or do
you have data to indicate that that's the case?
Okay, thank you so much.
Yes, this is a very good point. As I show in this patient population
that a few patients previously received surgery, so we
didn't collect
tumor tissue. However, we have recently reported in a
retrospective cohort of mesothelioma patients treated with anti-CTLA-4,
anti-PD-1, PD-L1, a strong correlation with
plasma and tumor methylation. So this suggests
that,
of course, plasma-derived TMMET score could be a
surrogate biomarker of tumor methylation.
And we are working also in a different cohort of melanoma patients resistant
to anti-PD-1, PD-L1. I will present the poster
on Tuesday. And in this population, we are
working on this in order to confirm, of course, in a prospective
larger cohort, these results.
Thank you. And again, feel free to come up and ask questions.
I do have one additional question.
In many respects, the plasma markers that you have obtained here
are arguably surrogates for
the volume of tumor that's there. And so
one question, and it's very hard to show this, obviously-
Yeah
... in a presentation, but
do you have a sense that these markers in the plasma
are yielding an independent data point that
helps predict outcome versus simply reflecting
things like what the radiographs would show or things that we already know that
tend to be predictive of long-term outcomes?
No. Okay. This is a very good point.
Of course,
this is a small number of patients, and
multivariate analysis also is difficult.
In terms of prognostic, this is
really well, but in terms of prediction, of course,
it is a randomized trial, so the randomization could
mitigate in part, of course this.
But
an important point, as I say, this patient population have
a higher tumor burden, not only in the brain but also
systemic.
So I think that this could be reliable as a correlation with
the systemic diseases and not only with brain diseases.
Yeah. I don't see-- Oh, there is a question. I apologize.
Yeah. Nice presentation. I have a question regarding the
cell-free DNA. Like, is the cell-free DNA coming from the
melanoma, or is it coming from the brain?
Like, does it depend on how much
tumor burden is in the brain?
Yeah.
Or how do you come-
What I said previously,
as I show in the demographic, the majority of patients had
more than three brain lesions and with the
longest diameter of two centimeters.
So the majority of patients had a high
tumor burden also in the brain. And a few
patients have also brain lesions.
If I remember correctly, only two patients have brain lesions.
The majority of patients have also visceral lesions in the lung
and in the liver.
And also, have you seen the baseline, how much cell-free
DNA was there compared to when you finished the treatment of the
patients?
Sorry, I didn't-
Was there a difference in
the number of cell-free DNA molecules in the blood when you
did the baseline and then after the treatment?
Like, how much was the difference in the tumor fraction?
You mean in terms of tumor fraction?
Yeah.
Yeah. As I show at this line, there is a few differences,
and
in arm C, we have the higher tumor fraction.
I have the slide. I presented the slide.
There is few differences at baseline in terms of methylation score, but
again, as I said, these are a few patients,
but we have the majority of patient arm C, and this is because
this is longer survival. And so I think that difference at
baseline in terms of tumor burden and tumor fraction, that is
not the issue.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Giacomo.
And thank you to all our investigators and the audience for
your participation and engagement, and to all the patients that participated in
this study. Thank you for your attention.